well fifty Shades obviously it's opening
everywhere and there's all this
merchandising there's so much
merchandise is something that isn't
party official merchandising who which
is amazing somebody as make a Christian
Grey cake but can you see the Christian
Grey cake I've seen it online well it's
right here it this is it so let's reveal
the Christian Grey cake look at that
[Applause]
it's no the lady who made it Rose
where's rose
oh there you are there you are firstly
you must have a very tall oven fancy but
how long did this take and it took a
team of four of us about two to three
weeks Wow come over and have a look at
this come on because I'm going to I'm
getting you give your taste in of it no
because we are allowed to eat it because
now tell us these things so that you it
comes with it comes with things these
are all edible as well yes
these are licorice yes good eating
they're real cute they're nice can I
have some no dude it's delicious how
come okay let's cook and I've got very
very very thick they kept 1200 afternoon
Graham the knife is very saw all the
guests so thank you very much
now road this is horrible but roses are
the best way to cut into it is in the
stomach so sorry Jamie okay
[Applause]
is this about right am i doing it right
now she says no no hang on brother down
here like that yeah Oh
has it got cream in it she got to say
I'm doing a very good job I've done a
very good job would make a lovely chest
of drawers hang on
I'll do a bit here here's the good
deeper going on there's a bit and get a
bit here look at that
that's lovely man that is great that's
it well I was doing very well now I'm
just tunneling how do you taste better
than I imagined
I made for an international cake show of
and we'd made a Red Room that's totally
edible and we're taking it to London so
he is for a reason he isn't just because
I he now is a rather unappealing hole in
this summer no delicious well on the
cake
[Applause]
show yourself did you enjoy them let me
discover that you get turned on by
Hoover does journey if you need a
cleaner just ring me up and I said why
well because